is it true that you met your husband at
the baramore theater theater my
grandfather aunt and uncle
yes well you're playing this like you're
there you meet my Broadway debut and um
it's such a storied important theater
it's such a beautiful theater when I was
there I was reading about Raisin in the
Sun being in that theater and it was my
first time on Broadway and now I write
about it in my book so it has another
fun Legend to F all the beautiful things
that have happened at that theater I'm
very excited that it took place there n
d what did you think when you first met
him did you have a a first sight thing
or was it a slow burn um it was this it
was a first is that funny what's this
why I'm just curious it was a little bit
of both I think and and I've talked to
you know you talk to people who like my
parents who've been married for as long
as they've been married I think both are
important I think that first sight thing
for me was really important and
undeniable but I think the Slow Burn is
what keeps you going you know we've been
married 10 years now so it's like an
immediate with a great Slow Burn that I
hope will keep burning I mean and you
have three beautiful children you've now
been married for 10 years yes just this
summer 10 years
congratulations a decade
yes I don't think I've seen a more
beautiful look in my life than when you
walk the red carpet with part of your
pregnant belly sticking out that did it
for me yeah thank you for empowering
women to like show their their full I
love everybody's doing it now I love it
there is so much to discover in this
Memoir but there is a fun fact actually
and I was wondering if we could quiz an
audience member on this fun fact okay um
where is Crystal Renee
oh you're Crystal Rene hi
hi um
Crystal we're going to give you a trivia
question which of the below facts is
true about Carrie a car's nickname was
condom Carrie in high school oh my
goodness B Carrie swam across the
English
Channel or C Carrie got dance lessons
from Janet Jackson don't answer because
we're going to go to quick commercial
break and we'll be right
[Music]
back